[Musique]
bonsoir les rateront ne m'interrompez
nounours bon soir les enfants
alors pas trop
[Musique]
savez-vous planter le chou non mais je
suis certain que toi tu sais nounours
oui moi je sais je vais vous l'apprendre
mon échelle hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
juliette à elle est partie quand les
gens ne vous en faites pas elle doit
venir elle est sorti prendre l'air
bonsoir savez-vous planter les choux non
bah oui c'est facile à apprendre via
prônent le oui à breuleux moi je vous
écoute
ses enfants de la vie tu sais sûrement
pas les parties à la mode de chez nous
avoue les enfants musique
ça lui vaut de l'hôtel les choux à la
mode est à la fois que savez-vous
planter les choux à la mater chine où on
lui plante avec le poids à la botte à la
peau de hongrie perd 4
savez-vous planter les choux à la botte
halloween c'est bien les chocs à la map
et chine où on lui planta de culture à
la beauté à la mode elle était fière
savez-vous planter les choux à la mode a
le vent de sa plaque elle échoue à la
maquette est chez nous on les plante
avec la fin à la faute à la mode
[Musique]
savez-vous planter les choux
le mode album de l'année pop
intelligente à la mater chine-ue on les
plante avec le genou à la mode à la mode
[Musique]
savez-vous planter les choux à la mode à
la beauté
les chants à la mater theshit où on lui
plante avec le nez à la mode pas la mode
[Musique]
savez-vous planter les choux à la botte
album
[Musique]
les plantes avec le coude à la mode à la
mode
[Musique]
savez-vous planter
fois plus haut
[Musique]
tiens échoue
je le temps
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça peut être drôle ma petite juliette a
mais j'aimerais bien savoir où tu as
pris sochaux elle a fait hurler qu'on
tient
bon mais maintenant soit sage juliette à
alon relu
saiem nous sommes couchés
treize enfants
exemple
tu ne dors pas la belle étoile
cornichons quand il fait humide j'ai des
roches ou trois ans en allant au menu
les enfants
bonne nuit nous nous
venus et les petits fait bora cornichons
sommes une annonce annie julie iata
[Musique]
bonnut nicolas bonnieu pas pr neil bonne
nuit cornichons et juliette à à demain
les petits endormez vous vite on route
ou en rouge fait pour
[Musique]
oh
e